YouTuber Mr Beast has come under Fire
this week for a video in which he paid
for cataract surgery to help cure
treatable blindness in a thousand people
on first glance it seems like a typical
case of Rich YouTuber philanthropy if
only on a much bigger scale than we used
to so why has this rubbed people up the
wrong way
all right I feel like we might catch up
to Mr Beast this year in terms of
YouTube subscribers it could happen it
could easily happen so if you haven't
subscribed make sure you do so now and
also give the video a like if you
enjoyed it thank you alright so for the
six people watching this who don't know
who Mr Beast is he is the biggest
YouTuber on the planet the only Channels
with more subs and him are collective
brands or projects such as Indian music
channel T-Series or coco melon nursery
rhymes although Mr Beast obviously
employs a team of people around him he
fits anyone's definition of a singular
YouTuber and in that category there's
simply no one bigger than him he boasts
over 129 million subscribers on his main
Channel alone and he once tweeted out
that one percent of all humans on Earth
watch his content across all of his
channels he's known for his extravagant
stunts games and challenges such as his
November 2021 squid game video which is
currently sitting at an astounding
355 million views he's also known for
his more altruistic videos in these
videos he'll use his wealth and fame for
more positive purposes in 2021 he helped
raise over 30 million dollars for team
Seas to help remove trash from the ocean
and the year before that he gave out two
hundred thousand dollars to people who
had lost their jobs during the start of
the pandemic and last weekend Mr Beast
posted a similar kind of video it was
titled 1 000 blind people see for the
first time and features Mr Beast working
with a surgeon to provide 1 000 blind
people with manual small incision
cataract surgery in this video we're
hearing a thousand people's blindness
it's gonna be crazy most of us see the
world like this but here's the thing 200
million people see the world like this
but I just made it one less
oh
wow all right let's get some of the
science out the way first cataracts is
the buildup of proteins and sugars on
the lens of an eye that can lead to
blurry vision and eventually blindness
manual small incision cataract surgery
is a relatively simple operation that
can reliably remove cataracts from
people's eyes and restore their Vision
this is something that Mr Beast touched
on in his video they can't see but we
have all the technology to fix it yep
half of all the blindness in the world
is people who need a 10-minute surgery
crazy yeah we also heard the stories of
a handful of patients in the video some
of them had had to give up their jobs
because of cataracts others haven't seen
family members properly in years and one
guy had never been able to drive a car
despite being a huge fan of them we saw
the emotional before and afters from the
patients as well as Mr Beast handing out
large sums of cash to a few of them or a
brand new Tesla to that car guy
literally I cannot put into words have
you ever driven a car before no now if
you go to the comments section of his
video or in his Twitter replies you'll
see plenty of appreciation for Mr Beast
praising him for directly improving a
lot of people's lives but of course I
wouldn't be sat here talking to you now
if that was the consensus across the
board almost immediately some people
called out the video for having a sort
of dystopian vibe to it that something
about it just felt disturbing even
demonic as one person put it now
everyone who felt like this expressed it
in different ways and for different
reasons but I'm gonna try and wrap it up
into a single cohesive Point here it's a
feeling that it's weird to live in a
society where something so simple and as
life-changing as this surgery is locked
behind a paywall it's not that Mr Beast
tearing down his paywall for a thousand
people is a bad thing of course not it's
a good thing within the current system
but it highlights how absurd the
existence of the paywall is to begin
with some feel the video as teaching
people especially the young but it takes
a messiah-like figure such as Mr Beast
to overcome this problem instead of a
society that comes together to ensure
that everyone has access to this kind of
healthcare so that people maybe don't
have to require the generosity of a
millionaire to be able to see a
relative's face for the first time I
watched the video and I'm filled with
rage
that we shut off access to a 10-minute
procedure because we pay walled it and
decided that like some people just
simply can't get it
it is so insanely frustrating that it
like it's up to like one YouTube guy to
like decide to make content out of it
did it like is it people who are too
poor can't just [__] see that's
insane now you may disagree with that
but Mr Beast actually said as much
himself posing the question of why
governments don't step in and help with
this sort of thing that even from a
financial standpoint there would be a
return on investment in taxes on those
able to work again but for a lot of
people this was just a load of
unnecessary complaining about Mr Beast
doing something good the people
shouldn't take their frustrations out on
him personally and that ultimately who
can be angry at someone curing blindness
and Mr Beast was perfectly capable of
defending himself on Twitter in this way
suggesting that you can't please people
on Twitter even if you use your wealth
for good obviously we all know that if
you do anything on the internet there's
always going to be a few people that
criticize you but this situation really
just feels like a kind of massive
misunderstanding one group is using a
situ operation to point out the
shortcomings of Health Care Systems and
the other is taking that as a sort of
personal attack on a YouTuber I totally
get the sort of dystopian vibe that some
people feel when they see this kind of
thing procedures like this should be
accessible to everyone in an Ideal World
these people wouldn't have to appear in
a Mr Beast video to get this surgery but
in this very unideal world that we live
in right now I think a thousand people
being cured of blindness is the second
best option it's a Band-Aid solution if
Mr Beast needs to film these videos in
order to be charitable and help these
people then for now so be it I think the
issue here for some people is not Mr
Beast it's not the video or what happens
in it it's what the video tells people
about how the world should work some
people are worried that it only
reinforces the idea that charity from
rich people is what can fix society's
problems not Society itself Mr Beast
will very likely be doing this kind of
philanthropy once again and when that
happens I'm sure this debate will flare
up until then let me know where you land
on all of this and I'll see you very
soon
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock
[Music]